it's beauty junkie time having beauty
rituals
and consistency together is what's
really important and that's why i'm
excited that we've teamed up with
olay to discuss morning and night time
rituals for a special segment we're
calling
good morning and good night
and joining us is the authority
of all things beauty editor-in-chief
of allure magazine my friend michelle
lee
hey drew oh hi michelle hi
how are ya i'm good thank you i'm
missing you in person
i know i'm so geeking out to just see
you it makes me so happy although
i'm always watching all of your videos
so i do feel
connected to you thanks to social media
and i
really respect i mean i call myself
a beauty junkie but you are like at the
top of the mountain
uh as far as i'm concerned i bow down to
your beauty knowledge and i loved the
subject of this
the good morning and good night had such
a romanticism to me
so okay when you wake up what is
your good morning yes so
as you know i had a baby recently i've
got a 15 year old a 12 year old and now
an
eight month old once i get her kind of
settled i then
start my skincare i think now that i've
got the baby i've simplified it a little
bit but
always cleansing absolutely doing like a
gentle cleanser
i then start to layer things so i'll do
an essence some sort of serums
and then also vitamin c so vitamin c
every single morning whether it's in a
serum or in a moisturizer
i've been using the olay vitamin c from
regenerist
this one is super great i find it really
hydrating i also love that there's no
fragrance in it
vitamin c is just like that powerhouse
ingredient of where it's really great
for hyperpigmentation for overall skin
brightness i am obsessed
i had moved to alaska for four months to
make a film and we were filming it in
winter and that
is when i started using regenerist very
loyally it
saved me from sitting outside for 12
hours and zero degree weather in the
driest of conditions
and that's when i became an olay
loyalist
okay michelle we've done the morning
routine now what is your
evening ritual um i usually start the
baby's bedtime routine
and then once the baby is asleep i start
my nighttime skincare routine
nighttime skincare routine is a little
bit more pared down i do the korean
double cleanse
i usually put on a couple different
serums and then i'll end with a retinol
and this one i love because it's just
gentle and hydrating exactly
i am totally loving this retinol 24 by
olay
it is super hydrating and it's such a
good price for this like powerhouse
ingredient
so retinol is basically vitamin a so if
you think about like the vitamin a foods
that we eat like carrots and you know
sweet potatoes and stuff it's that same
compound so it's also a vitamin that
it really penetrates deep into your skin
and it helps to stimulate
cell turnover so it's very different
from vitamin c but they also both kind
of help with skin tone
and brightening as well so that's why i
use retinol at night and vitamin c
during the day
okay allure has a new podcast launching
this week
and i've been a guest on the allure
podcast before and will you tell me
about it
i will so it was so nice having you as a
guest on the allure podcast when i could
see you in person
but yes we have one launching this week
called the science of beauty which we're
doing in partnership with olay
and so i'm co-hosting it with our
executive beauty director jenny bae
and so every episode we go into one
topic like sunscreen
pores pigmentation wrinkles vitamins
and we're talking to a lot of doctors
and just diving deep into
different myths answering a lot of
questions and i know a lot about skin
care and about ingredients but i feel
like i've learned so much just from
recording these episodes um michelle i
just started salivating
i'm not kidding my saliva glands just
like started
in overdrive because as a beauty
junkie enthusiast uh self-proclaimed and
you on the mountaintop of knowledge the
science
behind things i will be an avid listener
and i'm so glad i cannot wait to
listen to this so these products are
available at target and target.com
and guess what all of today's vfs are
going to go home with a 50
gift card from target
so you could olay and then some
and i just really want to thank um
michelle
who really we are so lucky to be
speaking with
someone of her caliber and her knowledge
and i am going to be
hooked on that podcast day one thank you
michelle so much for being with us thank
you
thank you so much for having me thank
you so much